[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravis de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui dans ce nouveau
numéro du skycho le magazine qui raconte
toutes les aventures économiques du
territoire de saant an new alors pour ce
nouveau numéro nous nous trouvons au
théâtre de C an newing car ici toute
l'après-midi la Task Force RH s'est
réunit en plinière une centaine de
professionnels RH des entreprises du
territoire se réunissaient autour d'une
thématique celle de l'offre de service
de cant en ieline pour les salariés
l'objectif mettre en valeur plusieurs
services que l'agglomération met en
place pour les salariés nous y
reviendrons un petit peu plus en détail
dans ce numéro mais tout de suite voici
le sommaire lieu dédié à
l'entrepreneuriat et à l'innovation
depuis 2017 le ski cuube accompagne les
porteurs de projets maison d'entreprise
incubateur ou encore tierslieu tout est
misise en œuvre pour favoriser
l'émergence et le développement des
entreprises dans ce numéro nous ferons
le bilan de cette année 2023 riche en
projet et en accompagnement la Task
Force RH se réunissait sous forme de
plignère au théâtre de 50 ans Yveline
pour cette deuxè rencontre de l'année
les membres échangeront à propos de
l'offre des services de 50 ans niveline
pour les salariés la troisème promotion
du programme entrepreneuriat pour tous
reçoit son diplôme cette initiative veut
repérer les ambitions entrepreneuriales
former les porteurs de projets les
accompagner et les intégrer à
l'écosystème
[Musique]
local au ski cube entreprendre et
innover sont les maîtrees mots depuis sa
création en 2017 l'incubateur a mis en
place plusieurs dispositifs pour
accompagner et soutenir les porteurs de
projets SK Cube est un lieu dédié à
l'entrepreneuriat et à l'innovation euh
il répond aux attentes des entrepreneurs
dans toutes les étapes de la vie d'une
entreprise aussi bien au niveau de la
création que du développement que de la
transmission et on essaie de de les
accompagner sur les thématiques diverses
et variées euh ça peut êtrejet de
l'emploi ça peut être sur le sujet du du
financement sur le sujet évidemment de
l'innovation avec not votre incubateur
et tout ça dans une logique
d'accompagnement à la fois individuel et
à la fois collectif chaque année le ski
cube accompagne près d'une vingtaine de
startup mais pas que en terme de
fréquentation on comptabilise globe sur
les créateurs d'entreprise environ 700
entreprise que nous avons accompagné
s'ajoute à ça les entreprises elles déjà
en activité on en a environ comptabilisé
sur cette année environ 300 300
entrepreneurs qui ont un moment donné eu
un lien avec les services de
l'agglomération et notamment de de de
ski cube en terme d'accompagnement donc
tout confondu on est environ à 1000
dirigeants d'entreprise accompagné pour
aider les entrepreneurs dans la création
et le développement de leur projet le
ski cuube propose d'autres offres parmi
elles initiative Sky alors initiative
Sky c'est une association loi 1901 dont
l'objectif est de promouvoir la création
d'entreprise dans la région de de 50 ans
en Yveline par l'attribution de prêt
d'honneur à des porteurs de projets qui
viennent nous voir
nous présenter leur projet il passent
devant un comité qui va très rapidement
évaluer l'intérêt et la viabilité du
projet et qui va ensuite leur attribuer
un prêt qui va entre 5000 et 100000 €
créé en 2009 l'association émane de
initiative France qui couvre l'ensemble
du territoire français aujourd'hui
hbergé au ski cuube initiative Sky est
plus qu'un simple outil de financement
on a la chance d'être hébergé au
skycube et d'être énormément aidé par la
Communauté d'Agglomération qui nous met
à
disposition du personnel et ces gens
vont pouvoir accueillir les porteurs de
projet travailler avec eux en amont leur
projet leur leur expliquer ben comment
monter un plan de financement comment
travailler leur business plan avant de
leur permettre de passer devant le
comité d'attribution en 2023
l'association a accompagné 37
entreprises et parmi elles il y a
emblématique garage basée à montinil
Bretonneux l'entreprise a pour projet de
rest resturer et réparer des véhicules
de collection on a aussi donc un service
de remisage de véhicules donc qui est
directement dans nos locaux et après on
a aussi donc la partie chicane qui est
donc coaching et stage de pilotage sur
circuit mais pour mettre en place ce
projet emblématique garage avait besoin
d'un coup de pouce on a fait appel à
initiative Skyp parce qu'on était dans
la recherche de
partenaires dans là où on voulait
s'installer nous on a toujours voulu
s'installer dans la région Ouest
parisienne et plus précisément en fait
dans le dans la région de an en yeline
en fait bah ça nous a tout apporté d'une
part pour le prêdhonneur euh parce que
c'est vrai que avoir le prêdhonneur bah
ça ça a débloqué un petit peu bah tout
ce qui était bancaire tout ce qui était
demande de fond pour point de vue des
banques de près de choses comme ça un
véritable levier pour Jordi Jonathan et
Quentin qui n connaissaiit rien à
l'entrepreneuriat on a trouvé chez Sky
cuube bah tout l'accompagnement à la
création de société c'est-à-dire que ce
soit des session avec des intervenants
la création du business plan ou les
choses comme ça c'est toute cette
préparation qui aurait été nettement
plus hasardeuse si jamais on avait pas
eu la chance de de pouvoir avoir le
soutien de de Sky cuube aujourd'hui
labéisé par BBI France le ski cube a
d'autres projets pour l'année 2024
l'incubateur veut notamment promouvoir
l'entrepreneuriat dans des quartiers
prioritaires grâce au dispositif CIT
[Musique]
laab pour la de fois cette année la Task
Force RH s'est réunie sous forme de
plainère ils étaient une centaine de
personnes cet après-midi au théâtre de
50 an nivin pour discuter de l'offre des
services que l'agglomération met en
place pour les salariés pour en parler
je suis avec Christelle bois bonjour
bonjour vous êtes responsable service
emploi de CTIN en Yveline tout à fait
alors tout d'abord est-ce que vous
pouvez expliquer ce qu'est cette Tasque
force RH al la Task Force RH c'est une
communauté de RH qui se réunit
régulièrement pour échanger sur des
sujets d'actualité entre RH donc des
problématiques de recrutement ou des
problématiques liées à leur activité
quotidienne dans leur entreprise
respectives on met en place bah des
séances comme aujourd'hui de rencontres
des afterwork des également des ateliers
de travail qu'on appelle nous des
workshops sur des thématiques bien
spécifiques de recrutement de
RSE ou tout simplement découvert de
nouveaux de nouveaux outils pour
faciliter encore une fois leur cô
qutidien ou engager des actions
collectives sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin et faire en sorte que les
opportunités d'emploi de Saint-Quentin
soient connu et aujourd'hui quel est le
thème particulier alors aujourd'hui
c'est donc une plinière donc on se
réunit en cette fin d'année autour d'un
d'un goûtter de Noël pour faire
connaître mieux connaître auprès des
entreprises qui font partie de la Tasque
force RH les services que propose
l'agglomération donc on va avoir les
services de l'habitat le service de la
mobilité également pour faire connaître
les différents moyens de transport pour
accéder aux sites et aux entreprises euh
le service des sports euh en vue des des
gios ça si prêt ils ont développé toute
une offre de service pour promouvoir
justement et lancer la dynamique des
Jeux Olympiques sur ce territoire et
puis la culture avec tout le réseau des
médiathèques ainsi que les nombreux
musées qui seront mis à l'honneur
aujourd'hui on a l'habitude de se réunir
régulièrement donc personnes assistent
d'autres nous rejoignent par parfois
mais tout ça dans une dynamique de
coopération et de collaboration entre
entreprises ou entre acteur du
territoire et c'est vraiment ce qu'on
recherche il y a pas d'adhésion c'est
c'est totalement gratuit c'est un
service proposé par l'agglomération pour
que tous ces acteurs fonctionnent mieux
se connaissent mieux et éventuellement
travaillent ensemble sur par exemple des
transferts de compétences d'une
entreprise vers une autre ouais
justement c'est ce que j'allais vous
demander comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
connaître la date des la date pardon des
plinières comment qu'on participe à ces
événements alors aujourd'hui c'est pas
grand public c'est ce sont des
invitations on va dire privées réservées
aux membres de la Task Force pour
justement éviter qu'on soit entre
guillemets parasité par des par des
personnes qui n'auraient pas des
intention que nous on souhaite voilà de
de de travail collectif et puis
constructif donc on passe par le service
emploi de de l'agglomération de 50 an en
yeline il faut être un RH ou en tout cas
un membre associé à la fonction de RH
pour pouvoir y faire partie ça existe
depuis 3 ans en fait on a mis en place
cet outil au moment du du covid
forcément c'était inédit pour elle pour
pour eux et la la la la gestion du
personnel à ce moment-là était tellement
euh voilà inédite surprenante que ils
ont senti ce besoin de d'échanger entre
pères et peut-être de confronter des
organisations les unes avec les autres
autrees chose que les plinières
peut-être vous organisez d'autres
événements particul oui alors on
organise donc des ateliers de travail où
là on peut avoir des ordres du jour qui
qui varient vraiment en fonction de
l'actualité et puis sinon on organise
des actions collectives que l'on déploie
sur le territoire notamment on a fait
une opération de street recruting enfin
on en a fait même deux une cette année
et une l'année dernière donc on se rend
sur le territoire auprès des gares dans
les gares de Saint-Quentin ou ou dans le
centre commercial pour aller proposer
les emplois de du territoire aux
passants aux salariés qui vont prendre
train pour Paris peut-être le matin pour
leur dire mais vous savez sur
Saint-Quentin il y a des emplois à
pourvoir on a des outils pour ça pour
vous y aider donc n'hésitez pas et puis
par ailleurs on fait aussi d'autres
actions plus plus plus peut-être plus
modestes sur des salons sur
Saint-Quentin mais aussi à l'extérieur
de Saint-Quentin sur Paris avec la PEC
notamment mais aussi dans des écoles
pour promouvoir encore une fois
l'ensemble des offres d'emploi du
territoire il y a eu également une
opération les Lutins de Noël qui a été
condu l'année dernière pour permettre à
des associations de sa-quentin de
bénéficier de jouets qui avaent été
collecté dans des dans dans des
entreprises et donné par des salariés
donc voilà plusieurs niveaux d'action en
fonction du groupe en fonction de ce qui
ressort de ces échanges on n pas
forcément une année identique à la
précédente donc là c'est la 3e année
donc on apprend aussi à se connaître à
fonctionner et là on va partir pour une
4e mannée avec un un un groupe de RH
très motivé alors merci beaucoupi mer
vous et nous justement on va aller
rencontrer certains de ces
[Musique]
participant ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ça va nous permettre peut-être de
d'adresser des nouveaux salariés qui
sont qui connaissent pas encore
aujourd'hui cette possibilité que
Saint-Quentin offre et de pouvoir
ensuite les les renseigner les
conseiller et les intégrer à notre
vivier de demandeurs je pense en
particulier pour les gens qui veulent un
logement social on est ici aujourd'hui
pour présenter l'ensemble des services
de mobilité que nous avons sur le
territoire on s'est dit que c'était une
bonne initiative d'être présent ce jour
pour promouvoir nos services de mobilité
et attirer les entreprise nous on va les
laisser débattre et on part tout de
suite à la remise des diplômes de la
3ème promotion du programme
entrepreneuriat pour
[Musique]
tous ils étaient 14 candidats à recevoir
leur diplôme le 20 décembre 2023 au ski
cube pour la 3e année consécutive le
programme entrepreneuriat pour tous
formait et accompagnait des porteurs de
projets l'objectif révéler leur Poti et
les aider à s'intégrer à l'écosystème
local l'idée c'était de de pouvoir
toucher un public qui est un petit peu
en dehors des dispositifs traditionnels
d'accompagnement et l'idée c'est
vraiment de les accompagner dans leur
parcours pour créer leur entreprise de
septembre à décembre 2023 les
participants ont pu bénéficier de 250
heur de formation gratuite un soutien
essentiel pour Amel et Sandrine qui
partaiit de zéro on a fait appel à
entrepreneariat pour tous parce que on
avait un concept et un projet et tout ce
qui n aller autour donc le statut
juridique euh le prix la gestion de
l'entreprise tout ça ça nous échappait
et on a décidé de se faire entourer et
on a bien fait puisque notre projet n'a
rien à voir avec il y a 3 mois ça nous
apporté beaucoup de confiance en fait on
avait besoin aussi qu'on nous dise que
c'était faisable et pour pour que ce
soit faisable il faut des éléments euh
il faut une sécurité et euh on l'a pu
l'acquérir ici à la skip puube j'ai
intégré entrepreneuriat pour tous qui
cube parce que j'avais besoin d'un coup
de pouce parce que l'entrepreneuriat
c'est pas quelque
chose que j'ai pu faire auparavant du
coup ça m'a permis là pendant 3 mois et
demi d'avoir des connaissances sur un
peu sur tous les aspects de la création
d'entreprise donc c'était très
enrichissant l'année dernière Isabelle
Bory a elle aussi pu bénéficier du
programme entrepreneuriat pour tous un
programme qui lui a donné toutes les
clés nécessaires pour fonder son cabinet
de sophrologie basé à morpa je pense que
ça m'a vraiment aidé à savoir quoi faire
à quel moment quelles étaient les choses
les plus importantes à mettre en place
dans un premier temps puis après et
faire les choses étape par étape et à ne
pas balayer certaines choses c'està-dire
par exemple bilan prévisionnel je pense
que j'aurais peut-être pas fait si
j'avais pas fait la formation ou
j'aurais pas su l'importance de l'étude
de marché voilà je pense qu' il y a des
étapes que j'aurais peut-être sauté si
je naavais pas fait le le programme
cette année entreprises ont déjà été
créées rendez-vous en 2024 pour le
lancement de la 4e
[Musique]
promotion on termine avec l'agenda les
mois prochains ne manquez pas le
webinaire Jeux Olympiques et paralympiqu
de Paris 2024 le 15 janvier 2024 de 15h
à 16h venez découvrir au ski cube le
site de célébration et les opportunités
business des jeux de paris 2024 le jeu
des affaires venez apprendre à piloter
votre entreprise de manière ludique au
ski cube le 1er f 2024 de 17h à 20h
venez apprendre en TR tours de dé les
fondamentaux de la gestion d'entreprise
et les bonnes actions marketing et
commercial grâce à un jeu de société
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78